Good Shit going on.
I'm getting offers and all sorts of different things and I'm like,
I,
I'm my own boss.
I'm not going to fire me.
I'm not going to accidentally tweet something one day and then go that I'm going
to fire Dave Rubin.
Like,
you know,
like my,
my fans fun most of what we do.
And it's like I need to grow.
Like we definitely need to grow because there's,
we're just,
my guys were just doing too much,
but I'm also very aware that the more we start growing,
but all the problems that you just laid out,
we'll start becoming more and more real.
So I like being a slim and trim as possible,
at least for now,
because I don't want to be down the road where we've had,
we got too many people.
There's too many,
just different competing interests and business interests and political
interests and everything else.
So it's like,
that's why,
I mean you're what you're doing here.
It's fricking,
it's amazing man.
So you know,
there was an article right after that IDW thing came out in the times that was
calling you a conservative.
And I think,
I think I emailed it to you.
I was like,
man,
it was the twitters,
Twitter things.
So the renegade conservative,
right?
That's what it was.
Pro Gay rights.
Pro Women's rights,
pro choice pro marijuana,
pro universal health care,
pro universal basic income.
Like what else do I have to do?
Like what other things am I,
oh pro second amendment.
He must be right.
Yeah.
Well Joe,
you're off.
You can't just have you,
what do you think?
You can have a series of thoughts that don't all lock in.
Would they be in a pattern that you have to be in the pattern?
I'm not just don't understand why someone's willing to be dishonest like that.
Like a sh a cursory examination of people's thoughts and positions on things
would lead someone to realize I'm definitely not a right wing person.
But the thing is that they own the narrative for so long that they can still get
away with it.
Yes.
And what's happening is now it's shifting and that's what I mean by I think
we're starting to win and I don't mean it when like we're going to destroy these
people.
I mean I think the narrative has started to shift a little bit where the
enthusiasm behind the conversations that we're all having,
whoever it is in this thing,
the enthusiasm is so great and there is no counter enthusiasts.
Like where are all the versions of us on the other side of this,
I'm gonna,
right?
No,
I don't even mean on the right,
like the people that really are selling identity politics at a really great way
at a comedy level who have a huge podcast and like where is the,
where is that intellectual set of people?
Where's the Sam Harris of the other side of this or the that have real
followings.
They don't exist.
And that's partly why the hysteria has been ramped up.
They can't believe that out of nowhere,
just because of our,
all of our just wherewithal and desire to do what we think is right or what
makes us happy or whatever the hell you want to call it.
They can't believe we all freaking created something.
Well,
they were all in a group.
I'm weirded out that we're in a [inaudible] group.
We're in a boy band or what?
I Guess Christina Hoff summers isn't that band too?
Who else is in that band?
Is Heather in it?
Yeah,
it has.
It has there.
I mean it looks,
we don't ever get to Brett.
Well you didn't get the car yet and get the card.
The clubhouse is under your studio.
Man.
Shapiro with joking around about it.
But like with the super friends?
Yeah,
like what is,
this was just the weirdest Avengers ever.
It's a weird group of humans.
I mean me and Ben,
we disagree on a lot of shit,
but we're super friendly to each other.
Like when I do his show or he does my,
I really enjoy that guy.
I like him.
You do freaking Shapiro show before my show.
Sorry,
what?
The guys had a shelf for three weeks.
Well,
this,
what are you feeling?
People were mad at me with the way I dressed.
See that.
They were like,
everybody else is wearing a nice shirt and a tie.
I'm like,
listen man.
I told the guy I was on my way to the comedy store.
You want to take a photo of me?
I'll be there.
You're not in the bush.
In the brush.
Yeah.
I should be in a bush.
Went up my ass.
I'm wearing a fucking chucks or converse and a some sort of a flannel shirt.
I bought that jacket,
Alaska.
I've just,
that's how it was.
Where I just,
what I was wearing at the comedy store,
Greenery.
Sure.
I said,
all right man,
that's what I'm wearing.
No greenery around.
The comedy store would have to go up to sunset,
but we'll ignore either way.
I just don't,
I don't give a fuck.
That's what I looked like.
That's who I am.
I'm not interested in portraying an image.
Just it is what it is.
You know?
It's like this,
this intellectual dark web,
like it's fucking Eric.
He's crazy.
And he's,
he gets mad when I call him crazy.
He loves it.
He's trying to get me to do,
are you on the whatsapp?
Oh,
I'm on the ones.
The little fucking check.
No,
I haven't jumped in yet.
I've been busy.
I don't have the time.
Just two or three messages for different group text conversations with comedians
were talking shit about things and talking around.
I'd have time for this.
I'm busy,
man.
All right,
well then you can't come to the club trying to make a yoga class.
I don't know.
Fucking time.
Yeah.
Who the hell goes like,
are we a group?
We do.
We have a meeting and shellacked cards and like we have in common,
I think we have a respect for our audience and intellectual curiosity,
you know,
electrical curiosity for sure.
Yeah.
And I think that's where,
that's where a guy like me and Shapiro,
although we have very different opinions on many different things,
you know,
I think we both are intellectually curious.
Yeah.
So think about it.
I've had been on many times,
I,
I consider him a friend.
We've,
we've broke bread together,
although he's kosher,
which makes it fucking pain.
What do you have to eat?
[inaudible] has such a smart guy.
Follow that blue,
do well.
I eat whatever the hell I to him about whatever I want,
but he usually bring something or you know,
has to launch.
You did a kosher restaurant.
I did eat it,
a kosher restaurant with him once,
but then it was all these orthodox Jews there and then they treat him like Jesus
and I was like,
dude,
I'm not a photographer.
You know what I mean?
I have to take all these pictures of him.
And they're like,
who's that guy?
I was like,
I'm not doing that again,
but it's funny,
but.